Antes de empezar, dejarme haceros una pregunta
¿Conocéis alguna empresa de Andorra? Mientras
os lo pensáis dejadme que os recuerde que
este vídeo ha sido posible gracias a SurfShark
VPN. Luego os doy más detalles pero antes,
vamos a ver un poco de historia.
Si os fijáis en el mapa de España, veréis
que hay un puntito justo en la frontera con
Francia. Ese puntito no es un error de imprenta:
es un país y se llama Andorra. Tiene 70.000
habitantes y, desde hace tiempo, se ha puesto
de moda en los medios españoles por noticias
como esta.
El Rubius anuncia que se muda a Andorra y
reabre el debate sobre el pago de impuestos
de los ‘influencers’
¡Exacto! Andorra se ha convertido en el destino
de moda de montones de YouTubers: principalmente
españoles ¡Pero no sólo hablamos de YouTubers!
Desde artistas hasta jugadores de póquer
profesional… Andorra parece estar a punto
de convertirse en una especie de Silicon Valley
del entretenimiento online. Y diréis ¿Qué
tiene este país que atraiga a tanta gente?
La respuesta es simple: impuestos bajos. Andorra
tiene uno de los tipos de impuestos más bajos
del mundo. En España, esto ha generado un
debate ideológico tremendo ¿Está bien o
está mal marcharse a otro país para pagar
menos impuestos? Y aquí no vamos a entrar
en ese debate. Porque hay una pregunta aún
más interesante… Una pregunta que casi
nadie se ha hecho en ningún medio. La pregunta
es esta… ¿Conocéis alguna empresa de Andorra?
Seguramente no. Y, a lo largo de este vídeo,
os vamos a explicar por qué. Pero antes hay
que hacer un paréntesis. En muchos medios,
se ha dicho que Andorra es un paraíso fiscal,
y eso no es cierto. Andorra puede tener impuestos
bajos pero no forma parte de ninguna lista
de paraísos fiscales. Al menos, no en este
momento. Recordad esto porque va a ser muy
importante a lo largo de este vídeo.
Lo que sí podemos decir es que Andorra es
uno de esos microestados europeos con impuestos
muy, pero que muy bajos. Sin embargo, fijaos
en esta gráfica.
A diferencia de otros microestados como Liechtenstein
o Mónaco, Andorra no es especialmente rico.
En 2018 tenía una renta per cápita de 42.000
dólares: es decir, estaba al nivel de Francia.
En otras palabras: que para atraer a tantos
millonarios, Andorra no es ni de lejos un
país ultrarrico.
Y la pregunta es ¿Por qué? ¿Por qué no
hay grandes empresas en Andorra pese a tener
unos impuestos tan altos? Y lo que es más
importante ¿De verdad Andorra puede convertirse
en un Hollywood para los YouTubers? Dicho
de otra forma: si eres un YouTuber y te estás
planteando mudarte a este país… ¿Es una
buena o una mala idea? Hoy vamos a responder
a estas preguntas pero antes… antes de hablar
de cambios de residencia fiscal, tenemos que
hablar de cambias de residencia virtual ¿Cómo
podemos evitar las restricciones geográficas
en Internet? ¿Cómo podemos evitar la censura
de ciertas dictaduras en Internet? ¡Con una
VPN! ¿Y cuál es la VPN favorita de VisualPolitik?
¡Pues claro que sí! Surfshark VPN. Surfshark
es una VPN fantástica y super segura. Por
ejemplo ¿No os ha pasado alguna vez que entráis
en una web y os salen un montón de ventanitas
de publicidad? Pues eso se llama PHISHING,
y por ahí se cuelan montones de cookies y
de virus que se meten en el móvil o el ordenador.
Pues, como ya sabéis todos, SurfShark tiene
una herramienta que se llama CleanWeb que
bloquea todos estos pop ups y todos estos
enlaces que tienen más peligro que un saco
de bombas ¡Pero no sólo eso! Con una única
cuenta de Surfshark podéis registrar todos
los dispositivos que queráis: el móvil,
la tablet, el portátil… ¡No hay ningún
límite de dispositivos!
Y como siempre, tenemos una oferta muy especial
para todos vosotros que seguís VisualPolitik.
Básicamente, si usáis el código “POLITIK”,
tendréis un 83% de descuento… más 3 meses
extra totalmente gratis. Es más, podéis
probar Surfshark durante los primeros 30 días
sin ningún compromiso. En la descripción
os dejo los enlaces.
EL PAÍS QUE QUISO IMITAR A LIECHTENSTEIN
Es imposible hablar de Andorra sin compararlo
con Liechtenstein. Parecen hermanos gemelos:
ambos son microestados, situados entre grandes
montañas y con impuestos bajos. Liechtenstein
tiene unos 30.000 habitantes, Andorra tiene
70.000. Liechtenstein está en los Alpes,
Andorra en los Pirineos. Ambos países son
principados, han mantenido cierto grado de
soberanía durante siglos y se mantuvieron
neutrales durante la Segunda Guerra Mundial.
Sin embargo, la Andorra que conocemos hoy
en día nació en 1982. Es en ese momento
cuando aprobaron la Constitución que tienen
hoy en día y cortaron todos los lazos de
dependencia que tenían con Francia. Y ahora
pensadlo por un momento ¿Qué haces cuando
tienes un país pequeño, aislado entre montañas
y sin grandes industrias? ¿Cómo puede prosperar
un país? Pues bien, Andorra decidió… imitar
el modelo de Liechtenstein. Así es como se
convirtieron en todo un paraíso fiscal: impuestos
bajos, IVA bajo o inexistente y, sobretodo
secreto bancario. Es decir, que los bancos
andorranos no estaban obligados a compartir
información de sus clientes con los estados.
Con esto, Andorra quería convertirse en todo
un centro financiero. Un Suiza o un Liechtenstein
de los Pirineos ¿El problema? El problema
es que nunca lo lograron. Durante décadas,
Andorra fue un lugar para esquiar, comprar
radiocasetes baratos y blanquear capitales.
Además, al ser considerados como paraíso
fiscal por casi todos los países europeos,
tenían un montón de restricciones para hacer
negocios. El caso de Liechtenstein es muy
distinto. Mientras la única gran industria
de Andorra era el turismo, Liechtenstein había
desarrollado su propia industria y sus propias
empresas. Sin embargo, todo cambió en el
año 2016.
El final del secreto bancario en Andorra dispara
las regularizaciones
De nuevo, al igual que hizo Liechtenstein
una década antes, Andorra acabó con el secreto
bancario. Eso explica que, desde el año 2018,
Andorra saliera de la lista de paraísos fiscales
de la Unión Europea ¡Y ya sé lo que pensaréis
muchos! ¡Esto sería el fin de la banca andorrana!
¡Toda una crisis para un país tan pequeño!
¿Verdad? Pues nada de eso. A partir de 2018,
Andorra entró en la lista de posibles destinos
para muchas grandes fortunas. Sobretodo, las
de aquellos que tienen negocios online ¿Por
qué? Ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
¿EL HOLLYWOOD DE LOS YOUTUBERS?
Imaginad que tenéis un pequeño negocio en
Internet. Podéis trabajar en cualquier parte
del mundo ¿Dónde viviríais? ¿En un país
como España, donde podéis llegar a pagar
más de un 45% de impuesto de la renta…
o en Andorra, donde sólo pagáis un 10%?
Hablamos de un microestado que está a 200
kilómetros de Barcelona. Incluso hay una
ruta de helicóptero Barcelona-Andorra. Aunque
el idioma oficial es el catalán, se puede
hacer la vida en castellano sin ningún problema.
Y diréis ¿De verdad es tan fácil mudarse
a Andorra? Pues lo cierto es que sí. Básicamente,
sólo hace falta pagar 15.000 euros a la Hacienda
andorrana y ser dueño de, al menos, el 21%
de una empresa local. Si no encuentras una
empresa, puedes crearla tu mismo. El capital
social son 3000 euros: lo mismo que en España.
La diferencia está en los impuestos: en España,
el tipo máximo de impuesto de sociedades
está en el 25%, en Andorra está en el 10%
¿Qué es lo que hace mucha gente? Se crea
una empresa y se pone un sueldo de 40.000
euros al año. Los primeros 24.000 están
libres de tributar. Los otros 16.000 euros
tributan a un 5%. El resto del dinero se cobra
en forma de dividendos de la empresa, que
están libres de impuestos. Sólo pagan un
10% por el impuesto de sociedades. Como veis,
parece un movimiento perfecto.
Y diréis ¿Pero cómo es posible que un estado
se financie con impuestos tan bajos? En principio
debería ser posible. El 58% de los contribuyentes
son extranjeros, muchos de los cuales tienen
rentas altas. Y digo “debería ser posible”
porque, en realidad, Andorra tiene unos agujeros
en sus cuentas importantes. Pero de eso hablaremos
más adelante.
Y diréis ¿Pero de verdad es tan fácil?
¿De verdad la Hacienda Española no puede
hacer nada perseguir a los ricos que emigran
a Andorra? Lo cierto es que… no. Básicamente,
si vives en Andorra más de 183 días y tu
principal centro de interés económico está
fuera de España… el Estado no puede hacer
nada contra ti.
Y diréis ¡Pero un momento! Si un YouTuber
tiene un canal en español, sus ingresos vendrán
de España ¿Verdad? La respuesta es que no.
Los anuncios y patrocinadores vienen de muchos
lugares distintos. Lo mismo pasa con la audiencia.
En realidad, con la ley actual, sólo hay
una forma de perseguir a alguien que tribute
en Andorra: demostrar que no vive o no trabajo
ahí. Por ejemplo, si un YouTuber andorrano
montara una empresa en España y todos sus
ingresos vinieran de ahí, si podría tener
un problema. De hecho, existen ejemplos de
artistas que fingían vivir en Andorra y que
finalmente han caído en las garras de la
Hacienda Española. Atentos.
Shakira afrontará una causa penal por defraudar
14,5 millones a Hacienda
Y os preguntaréis ¿Pero por qué alguien
iba a querer montar una empresa fuera de Andorra?
¿No se supone que Andorra es el lugar idóneo
para hacer negocios? Y aquí es donde viene
lo que nadie os ha contado de este país.
Veréis, cuando empezamos la investigación
para este vídeo, pensábamos que Andorra
podía convertirse en todo un Hollywood para
YouTubers. Sin embargo, a medida que buscábamos
información, nos llamó la atención una
cosa. Puede que Andorra tenga la mayor concentración
de YouTubers famosos per cápita de todo el
planeta tierra. Sin embargo… no tienen grandes
estudios de grabación, ni Networks, ni ningún
tipo de empresa auxiliar. Y diréis ¿Por
qué? Pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
POR QUÉ ANDORRA NO ES LIECHTENSTEIN
Una cosa es cierta: Andorra sabe cómo atraer
grandes fortunas. Pero volvemos a la primera
pregunta del vídeo… ¿Conocéis a alguna
empresa andorrana? Por ejemplo, Irlanda también
es un país famoso por tener bajos impuestos.
Eso explica, en parte, por qué las grandes
tecnológicas elijen este país para establecer
sus sedes europeas. Google, Facebook o Apple
tienen oficinas enormes en Irlanda ¡Pero
no sólo hablamos de empresas extranjeras!
Ryanair o Primark son compañías internacionales
nacidas en Irlanda. Y algo parecido pasa con
Liechtenstein. Podéis recorrer Liechtenstein
de Norte a Sur en sólo 15 minutos en coche.
Y durante todo el viaje sólo veréis fábricas
y oficinas, una detrás de otra. Y ya sé
lo que estaréis pensando muchos ¿Liechtenstein?
¡No conozco ninguna empresa de Liechtenstein!
Pues os equivocáis ¿Os suena una empresa
llamada HILTI? Son el líder mundial en herramientas
y maquinaria de construcción. Es más, seguro
que muchos de vosotros tengáis una taladradora
marca HILTI en vuestra caja de herramientas.
Y da igual donde viváis: si os vais a cualquier
obra de construcción encontraréis estructuras
diseñadas por esta empresa. Tienen presencia
en todo el mundo. Pero su fábrica más importante
y su centro de I+D está en Schaan, que es
un pueblecito de 6000 habitantes situado en
el Principado de Liechtenstein ¡Pero no sólo
eso! La próxima vez que vayáis al dentista,
fijaos en las máquinas que tenéis alrededor.
Seguro que muchas tienen el logotipo de IVOCLAR
VIVADENT. Esta empresa es la líder mundial
en prótesis y maquinaria para dentistas.
Y, de nuevo, su principal fábrica está también
en Schaan, Liechtenstein.
Sin embargo ¿Cuál es la empresa tecnológica
más importante de Andorra? “Andorra Telecom”,
la empresa que se dedica a proveer de Internet
y teléfono a los habitantes de Andorra. ¡Wow!
¡Cuidado Silicon Valley, que llega Andorra
pisando fuerte!
En todos los listados de empresas andorranas
que hemos encontrado sólo hay sociedades
unipersonales. Empresas que ni siquiera tienen
página web.
Sí, mis queridos amigos de VisualPolitik,
tener impuestos bajos no es sinónimo de tener
un sistema económico competitivo. Y Andorra
es el ejemplo perfecto.
Y diréis ¿Pero qué problema tiene Andorra?
¿Por qué no han conseguido crear grandes
empresas? La primera razón es el terreno.
En un país tan pequeño y tan montañoso,
es difícil encontrar terreno para construir
oficinas. Fijaos en esta noticia del año
2020.
Nueva promoción de lujo en el centro de Escaldes-Engordany
en un impresionante rascacielos
Ese “impresionante rascacielos” tiene
20 plantas y es el primer edificio alto que
se construye en Andorra. Y fijaos bien, porque
se trata de un edificio residencial. Es decir,
que no es un edificio de oficinas.
Y diréis ¿Pero qué problema tiene Andorra
para que nadie quiera montar empresas por
aquí? Atentos.
DEL PARAÍSO FISCAL AL INFIERNO EMPRESARIAL
Imaginad que sois un gran YouTuber y vivís
en Andorra. Hasta aquí no hay problema. El
problema es si queréis crecer. Vamos a suponer
que tenéis vuestra sociedad creada pero ahora
queréis dar un paso más y convertirla en
una productora mediana, con guionistas, editores
y animadores. Pues bien, en el primer año,
sólo podéis contratar a dos personas. Así,
tal cual como lo oís ¡Pero esperad porque
esto no es lo peor! La legislación laboral
andorrana es más nacionalista que el peluquín
de Donald Trump. Y su premisa es “los andorranos
primero”. Eso significa que, por ley, estaréis
obligados a priorizar a los andorranos por
encima de cualquier otra persona. Para traerse
a alguien de fuera, hay que pasar por un infierno
burocrático. Eso explica por qué, fuera
de las grandes fortunas, Andorra es incapaz
de atraer talento.
Por seguir con la comparación: Liechtenstein
se ha convertido en un todo hub de industria
médica y de alta precisión. Si sois ingenieros,
podéis intentar buscar trabajo por aquí.
Cada día, miles de personas, que viven en
Austria y Suiza cruzan la frontera para trabajar
en los polígonos industriales de este país.
Sin embargo, Andorra sólo atrae a profesores
de esquí y camareros.
¡Pero esperad un momento! Porque este no
es el único problema ¿Recordáis que os
dije que Andorra no ha sido capaz de crear
grandes bancos? Pues eso también es un problema.
Desde que acabaron con el secreto bancario,
los bancos andorranos pasan más controles
burocráticos que los de cualquier otro lugar.
Suiza tiene varios de los bancos más grandes
del mundo. Liechtenstein tiene el banco LGT,
que es propiedad de la familia real. Para
que os hagáis una idea, Standard and Poors
le da un rating de A+ y está considerado
como uno de los bancos privados con mejor
reputación del mundo ¿Qué tenemos en Andorra?
Su banco más importante es el AndBank. Según
la agencia de calificación Fitch, tiene una
calificación de BBB. Y no, la B no es precisamente
de “bueno”.
¡Pero esperad porque todavía no hemos terminado!
Sigamos con el ejemplo del YouTuber. Somos
un creador online y queremos hacer crecer
nuestro negocio. Vale, no podemos traer talento
fuera, tenemos problemas para conseguir financiación
pero… ¡No pasa nada! Podemos asociarnos
con una empresa de ecommerce y lanzar nuestra
propia marca de merchandising. Puede que os
sorprenda pero esta es la principal vía de
ingresos de muchos canales. Sin ir más lejos,
SallyWeilt en Alemania o Jeffrey Starr en
Estados Unidos han montado auténticos emporios
gracias a vender sus propios productos a través
de sus canales ¿El problema? El problema
es que Andorra no es parte de la Unión Europea.
Ni siquiera del Mercado Común. Mientras Liechtenstein
es el puente que une Suiza con la Unión Europea,
Andorra no es un lugar competitivo para tener
un almacén. Y diréis ¿Cómo es posible
entonces que Andorra atraiga a tantos dueños
de ecommerce? Por esto:
Dropshipping en Andorra: un modelo de negocio
muy rentable
Exacto, la mayor parte de los ecommerce de
Andorra utilizan el método dropshipping ¿Y
qué es el dropshipping? Pues en lugar de
tener nuestro propio almacén, usamos parte
de otro. Por ejemplo: supongamos que montamos
una tienda de zapatos. Yo gestiono la tienda
online desde Andorra. Cuando el cliente español
hace una compra, el almacén de China manda
los zapatos al cliente. Es decir, que yo ni
siquiera llego a tocar el paquete. Esta opción
es muy buena para ecommerce que están empezando.
Pero tiene dos grandes problemas: márgenes
muy bajos y tiempos de entrega eternos. Efectivamente,
muchas empresas del sector han empezado usando
esta técnica. Pero, en cuanto adquieren un
volumen, terminan usando sus propios almacenes.
Y ahí es donde la situación aduanera de
Andorra es de todo menos competitiva… pese
a los impuestos bajos.
En otras palabras, que si Andorra quiere convertirse
en un Silicon Valley del ecommerce, un Hollywood
de YouTube o un Las Vegas del poquer online,
más vale que haga reformas. Reformas serias
y probablemente impopulares.
Y ya sé lo que estará pensando alguno ¿Y
para qué quieren tener empresas? A fin de
cuentas, tal y como están viven bastante
bien. Y sí, tenéis razón: los millonarios
son a Andorra lo mismo que el petróleo es
a los países del Golfo; su principal fuente
de ingresos ¿El problema? El problema es
que no puedes depender de la llegada de profesionales
de renta alta. Además, si no hay razones
empresariales para retenerlos, es probable
que muchos se marchen. Más aún si tenemos
en cuenta que Andorra no cuenta con políticas
de integración. Más bien al contrario (por
cierto, que esta es otra diferencia con Liechtenstein).
Si dentro de unos años, muchos de estos millonarios
se marchan, dejarían un buen agujero en la
recaudación. Y, por extraño que suene, en
Andorra saben lo que significa tener déficit.
El presupuesto de Andorra para 2019 presenta
el déficit más bajo de la última década
Esta noticia es de 2019, un año después
de que Andorra dejara de ser declarado un
paraíso fiscal. Es decir, un año después
de que comenzara la oleada de YouTubers, jugadores
de póquer y pequeños empresarios. Pues bien,
en ese ejercicio, Andorra cerró con un déficit
del “sólo” 2,7%. Para este año 2021,
estiman que van a cerrar con un déficit del
16%. Y diréis ¿Pero cómo puedes tener problemas
de déficit en un país lleno de millonarios?
Pues porque ingresan poco y gastan más de
lo que deben ¿En qué? Pues, por ejemplo,
en cosas como esta.
El aeropuerto de Andorra La Seu podría tener
varias compañías operando el próximo invierno
Habéis oído bien: pese a tener 70.000 habitantes,
Andorra comparte un aeropuerto con España
(De nuevo, esta es otra diferencia con Liechtenstein.
Aunque Liechtenstein tenga una renta per cápita
4 veces más alta que Andorra, no tiene aeropuerto).
Pues bien, en el momento en el que hacemos
este vídeo, este aeropuerto no tiene ningún
vuelo comercial y cuesta 300.000 euros al
año a los andorranos. Puede parecer poco
dinero, pero recordad que toda la recaudación
de Andorra en 2021 va a ser de 397 millones
de euros. Así que, señores del Gobierno
de Andorra, si estáis viendo este vídeo,
creo que tenéis tareas pendientes. Si queréis
más información, aquí podéis ver la entrevista
que le hicimos al Príncipe de Liechtenstein,
el señor Hans Adam II. Está en inglés pero
seguro que os da alguna idea. Antes de terminar,
me gustaría dar las gracias a Andorra Solutions,
a Vicente Rojo y a Samuel Rodriguez, de EcommerceNews,
por habernos ayudado con la investigación.
Mientras tanto, ahora la pregunta es para
vosotros ¿Creéis que Andorra va a hacer
las reformas necesarias para convertirse en
un Hollywood YouTuber? ¿O existen lugares
mucho mejores para vivir? ¿Cuál os parece
el mejor lugar para vivir y montar empresas?
Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Y como siempre, no olvidéis que sacamos vídeos
nuevos todas las semanas así que suscribíos
a VisualPolitik y dadle a la campanita para
no perderos ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones.
Si os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE
y nos vemos en el próximo. Un abrazo y hasta
pronto.